Welcome back. So I'm really excited today to
tell you about Gauss's divergence theorem.
This is one of the most important results in all
of vector calculus and it is probably the primary
building block of how we derive conservation
laws from physics... from science. Conservation
of mass, momentum, and energy and translate into
partial differential equations. So I'm going to
walk you through this theorem with pictures, with
words, with math. So the idea is that we have some
some volume V and we're going to say that this has
a surface S and that there is some normal vector
at every point on the surface of this volume. And
so what Gauss's theorem does is it essentially
tells us if we have some fluid flow, some vector
field -- I'm just going to draw some some vector
field going throughout all of space like this --
and my vector field I'm going to call F-arrow. So
if I have that vector field and it's carrying mass
or momentum or energy through this volume, Gauss's
divergence theorem is going to allow me to compute
how much of that material is fluxing through the
surface of this closed surface, or what is the
rate of change of that material in this volume.
So it's a really useful way of doing essentially
accounting of physical quantities that we know
are conserved, like mass, momentum, and energy,
and using those to get quantitative expressions.
Now one of the things that I think is really
important is intuitively motivating why we
want Gauss's theorem. So when I learned about
this it was essentially just written down as a
mathematical fact and it was proven and I think
that's almost a crime not to tell you all of the
cool physical applications of Gauss's divergence
theorem. So I'm going to write it out in words,
give you the mathematical expression, and then
show you how we actually use this to compute
partial differential equations. So this is one of
the lectures I'm most excited for because I think
this is going to be a tool set or a tool in your
arsenal that you're going to use for the rest of
your career. This is a really powerful way of
thinking about the world. I mean it has Gauss's
name in it -- if it's Gauss's divergence theorem,
it's probably the best divergence theorem. Okay
so let's get started. So I'm going to start in
words so and I'm going to write this out somewhat
slowly, and then we're going to write out the
math expression. So in words, what we're saying
is that the flux of a vector field -- and our
vector field is F -- the flux of vector field F
out of a closed surface -- so let's say through
a closed surface -- and this closed surface is
S... okay the perimeter of this volume is S, and
so the flux of a vector field through this closed
surface is equal to the integral of the divergence
of that vector field throughout the entire volume.
I'm going to say this again and write it. The flux
of our vector field through the surface is equal
to the integral of the divergence of our
vector field -- the divergence div(F)
over the entire volume -- and I'll just
write it here over the entire enclosed
volume V. Okay so this is a bit of a mouthful
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
walk you through what this statement means, why
it's important, and we're going to translate it
into a mathematical expression. So maybe I will
start with the mathematical expression and then
we'll go back to what these words mean. So the
flux of a vector field F through a surface,
and I'm going to write this out in math, maybe I
will write it in blue, so the flux of our vector
field through this surface is going to be a
surface integral... so I'm going to integrate
over my surface S and the flux is essentially
how much of F is pointing in the normal direction
added up over every little surface element. So
if I want to compute at every point how much of F
is being kind of carried out of this volume --
what I do is I take my my F vector and I take my
normal vector n and I *dot* them together and
that tells me how much of my F component is
in a direction that will actually take me out of
this volume. So let's think for a minute... if my
F vector field was just swirling around in
this volume kind of going around in circles
and it had no component that was perpendicular
to the volume then nothing would be carried out
of this volume through that vector field
-- it would just be kind of recirculating
but nothing would be leaving and that dot product
of F if it was tangent to the normal would be
zero dot product with n. And so the way we say
this is the surface integral of our vector field F
dotted with the normal integrated over over
that volume, over every little area element
on the perimeter of this, so this is the flux
of the vector field F... this is literally the
definition of what I mean by the flux: this is
how much stuff is being carried out of the volume.
It's this: we compute how much of F is pointing
in the normal direction using the dot product,
and we integrate that up over the entire surface.
And that's how much stuff is leaving the volume...
this is basic accounting... this is the only way
stuff can leave the volume. Unless we believe
that stuff can be created or destroyed inside
the volume. Okay, so if our quantity like mass,
momentum, or energy can't be created or destroyed
and it's conserved then this is a basic accounting
of how much stuff leaves through that
surface s and so we call this the flux
through s the flux through s and this is
like a definition of the flux and what
Gauss's divergence theorem says that this flux...
this might actually be kind of a pain to compute
maybe I don't want to do the surface integral
what this is equal to is a volume integral
so we'll do a triple volume integral over the
entire volume of the divergence of F of
div dot F dv ... and this is extremely useful.
What this says is that these two quantities
are completely equivalent ways of computing the
flux through some volume and this is for an
arbitrary volume, it doesn't matter what size V
is... it could be a skinny little rod it could be
a sphere it could be a little hockey puck
shaped thing it doesn't matter what this volume is
this is always true as long as F is a continuous
vector field, if it doesn't have sharp abrupt
changes or shock waves then this is going to
be true... this is Gauss's divergence theorem.
And this is really important, so I'm
actually going to box this off.
This is super important,
this is Gauss'sdivergence theorem
We'll put some stars next to it just so that we remember that
this is really really important.
Okay so I'm going to restate why this is true.
I'm going to show you some intuition of why
this expression should equal this expression and
then we're going to use this to actually compute
some real conservation laws and translate
those into partial differential equations.
Things like the mass continuity
equation or the Navier-Stokes equation.
So why do we think that this volume
integral of the divergence of F should equal the
amount of stuff being carried out of F. So
I'm going to draw another little picture
here... I'm going to try my best to
duplicate this so that we can play around.
So that's roughly my volume and what
we're going to do, is we're going to chop
this up into a number of little boxes...
so I'm going to chop this up into some boxes
and I'm not a fantastic artist, so
we're just going to use a few boxes here
and what we're going to do is look at the
divergence in each of these boxes.
So in your imagination, imagine that this is a really fine
graph paper with millions or trillions
of boxes and you could take the limit as all of
those boxes become infinitesimally small
that's what we're going to do, and we're going to look at
the divergence at every little grid box
in this graph paper representation,
so atevery little point here, what I'm going
to do is I'm going to draw a representation of
the divergence, and what we're going to have
is that maybe I have some positive
divergence here and some positive divergence here
let's say my flow is kind of expanding
and some positive divergence, okay I'm just going
to draw this. I'm not going to draw any of these
negative because it's a little harder to visualize
and I've got this guy here.
Now the idea is, andthis is again requiring that my vector field F is continuous to do the divergencetheorem...
to kind of take this limit as all of these grid cells become
infinitesimallysmall and the argument I'm about to to
give you is the following... and I really
like this picture it just looks super cool
so these pink sources, the way I'm drawing
them here, these are the divergence fields locally
that are induced by this this flow F so
this F might be doing something complicated
you know there's some complicated
physics, Navier Stokes fluid flow, whatever
and this is the local divergence at every littlepoint.
Now what we observe is that if I really do
assume that this this vector field is continuous
and I make this grid infinitesimally fine
then these neighboring boxes, the positive
upward component of this flux and the negative
downward component of this flux should cancel each
other out, because if i make my boxes small enough
the flow is basically identical in neighboring
boxes and so the upward component of this pushing
on the downward component of this cancel out.
So you actually get this kind of cancellation of
all of the inner boxes every box that shares awall... those two neighboring forces are going to
cancel each other out and the only
thing that you're going to be left with is
this perimeter of all of the
divergences that don't have a neighboring
grid cell, so all of these these little
boxes that are pointing out this is the only
thing that's left when I integrate over this
volume.
Okay so i'm going to say this again
when i integrate all of my divergences over this
volume when i integrate all of my divergence on
this volume all of the inner grid cells kind of
cancel each other out because of the continuity of
f because f is a continuous vector field and i'm
making these these boxes infinitesimally small the
you know the right vector and the left vector
on neighboring grid cells cancel each other out
and the up vector and the down vector on
neighboring grid cells cancel each other out
and so we only have this thin perimeter right
on the surface of our volume that don't have uh
divergence vectors that are being cancelled
out and you'll notice that if i integrate
these along that looks a heck of a lot like my
flux through through the volume so this is a
very cartoony sketch of why gauss's divergence
theorem is true it's because i can take i can
integrate this flow kind of dotted with the normal
along the surface or i can compute its divergence
everywhere throughout the volume and just add up
all of those divergences the ones in the middle
will cancel each other out and it will leave kind
of something that's equivalent to this integral on
the perimeter so that's a really useful in my mind
kind of cartoon of why this is why this is true
okay so let's uh the way i talk about this
uh when i'm teaching this in class this is
essentially just accounting this is uh you know
being counting of some quantity being flown
through a vector field and so as long as you can
count things you know this these arguments have
to be true the stuff coming into a volume has to
equal the stuff coming out of a volume unless you
have sources you know that are kind of creating
things or destroying things inside the volume
okay good and there's a lot of ways you can
compute with this so for example if i want
to compute the volume of an irregular shape i
can create a vector field that has divergence
divergence 1 and i can integrate that
vector field all along the perimeter
of my volume i'm going to say that again if i
want to compute the volume of an irregular object
all i have to do is create a vector field that has
divergence one and then i integrate that vector
field along the perimeter or along the surface
of my volume dotted in the normal direction
that will equal the volume of that object so
that's kind of a neat application of gauss's
theorem but that's a little esoteric what i really
really really want to show you is how we can use
this to derive partial differential equations
so let me just say gauss's divergence theorem
for pdes for partial differential equations
and this is really exciting okay so
all of our modern physics all of uh kind of
you know the textbook equations that you're
you're used to seeing the navy or stokes equations
you know maxwell's equations almost all of our
physical laws boil down to a conservation of some
quantity in some volume using gauss's theorem to
derive a partial differential equation so it's an
extremely extremely powerful way of mathematically
quantifying uh physics and that's what i'm going
to show you right now so we're going to look at
gauss's theorem for the conservation of mass in a
volume okay so we're going to specifically look at
mass conservation
mass conservation uh in a volume and
we're basically assuming that we have some
fluid flow you know uh maybe we're in the gulf
of mexico maybe this is the flow in the ocean
and maybe i have some oil spill at some point in
the in the gulf of mexico maybe that's what this
this uh this volume is or maybe there's some some
spill here and we know that that is a conserved
quantity there's not you know more or less um
you know at least in the short term as it flows
through and so we want to somehow quantify
this conservation uh of mass in our volume
so here's what we're going to do we're going to
say that our total mass let me see i want to write
that here so our total mass in the volume equals
the triple integral over v of the density rho
dv okay so i'll just say rho is the density
so the density of whatever my
fluid is if i integrate that whole
you know that density over the entire
volume i will get the mass in that volume
and so the rate of change of that mass and the
volume is equal to how much of that flow that
mass is being fluxed out of that volume
through this surface integral so that's
what i want to write down this is the the basic
conservation i want to write down so the so d dt
of this integral which is rho dv integrated over
the volume this is the total this is the rate of
change of mass in my volume so maybe mass is being
carried out of my volume maybe mass is coming into
my volume and it's happening because this vector
field this fluid flow is either carrying mass
in or carrying mass out and so this rate of
change equals the only way that that mass can
enter or leave this volume is through it
being carried out through the boundary
by this flow f so this would equal
minus the integral through the surface
of my you know my mass that's being carried
out through the normal direction d s and i
have this minus sign because essentially if
i have a positive flow carrying mass out of
my volume if this f dot n is a positive thing
carrying flow out then that is a negative rate
of change of mass inside the volume so the rate of
change of mass inside the volume is equal to minus
how much of it is leaving the volume and again
this is the only way mass can leave the volume
is that if it's carried out through this
flow kind of normal to uh to that volume
okay so this is this is the basic setup this is
again just a counting this is just counting the
mass in my volume here and counting how much
mass enters and leaves my volume here good
but what we want these are are this is a triple
integral and this is a double integral and what
we want is to somehow you know write these in
the same triple integral formulation so i want to
convert this into a triple volume integral and i'm
going to use gauss's divergence theorem to do that
so we're going to turn this into a triple
integral by using gauss's divergence theorem
and the way we do it is as
follows so we're going to say
this quantity here is equal to minus the
triple volume integral of the divergence
of this quantity right so the the surface
integral of some flux dotted with a normal
is equal to the volume integral of the divergence
of that vector field so this is divergence of rho
f dv and remember rho my density is just
a scalar it's just a number at every point
in space and f is a vector field it's my
flow that's carrying this mass in and out
so now i have an apples to apples uh kind of
comparison before it was apples and oranges i had
a volume integral and a flux surface integral now
i have a volume integral for the rate of change
in time of my mass equal to this kind of spatial
divergence of rho times my vector field f and so
what's really neat about this is that i can move
this over to the left hand side and now i can put
everything under the same triple volume integral
and i'm going to move my ddt inside of here
okay and and this is really going to be a partial
of rho rho is a function uh let me write this down
so my density uh rho is a function of space let's
say x y z but also of time okay this density
might be changing i might have a compressible
fluid you know if i'm flying a jet the air is
compressing and the density is changing as that
wing or the nose or whatever is hitting the air
okay so sometimes this can change in space
and time it can vary and so what i'm going
to eventually get when i bring this all under the
integral is that i have a triple volume integral
of uh partial rho partial t the partial
derivative of rho with respect to time
now this minus when i bring it over
becomes a plus plus the divergence of rho
times my fluid velocity field all of this dv
equals zero so this is pretty special okay
this uh equation here essentially accounts
for all of the change of mass due to uh like
the mass changing in time things fluxing through
the surface and things like that and when you add
that all up it has to equal zero this
is a statement of conservation of mass
now here is one of my favorite parts of this whole
story of how you use gauss's divergence theorem
to derive partial differential equations is
that this is true this is true for all volumes
for all volumes v this is true if i had a big
volume v a stretched out volume v it's also true
if i take my v and i take the limit as it becomes
a teeny tiny tiny little delta v this is true
at every little patch uh in space if i shrink my
volume down to that little patch in space this is
still true and the only way that this integral can
equal zero for all volumes is if the thing inside
of it equals zero everywhere and so this is how
we derive our partial differential equation this
thing inside has to be equal to zero for this
volume integral to equal zero on all volumes
and so then we finally get partial rho partial
t plus the divergence of rho times my vector
field f equals zero and this is called the
mass continuity equation mass continuity
continuity equation and it's one of the
fundamental equations in fluid mechanics this is
the equation that quantifies conservation of mass
in a flowing fluid in the air when i'm speaking
you know air is moving but it's still the mass is
conserved this room mass is not being created or
destroyed and so this equation is true everywhere
in in space and in time okay even if i have a jet
moving through even if it's a compressible fluid
flow this is still true um it is only not true
when uh when my vector field f is sufficiently or
my density rho is sufficiently non-continuous if
it has a really sharp step change in space or in
time then this these derivatives don't actually
make sense they would go to infinity and i can
only represent kind of the integral effect in
a control volume that's large enough to include
that discontinuity okay so what i'm going to do
i'm going to take a step back and summarize and i
think in the next video i'm probably going to dig
a little bit deeper into this mass conservation
equation and show you what happens for example if
i have an incompressible flow if my density is a
constant then we can get specific kind of we can
derive specific quantities that have to be true
for this fluid flow f okay but let's talk about
the whole pipeline here if i have physics physics
is generally written in terms of conservation laws
we have conservation of mass conservation of
momentum conservation of energy newton's second
law is essentially a statement of conservation
of mass uh sorry conservation of momentum okay
you know the rate of change of momentum is
equal to the forces applied to the system
we can encode those conservation laws through
integral equations like this we literally count
how much stuff we have in a volume and how much it
changes in time and we say that the only way that
that can that the amount of stuff in that volume
can change that mass or momentum or energy is if
it enters or leaves through the surface of that
volume so i have a volume integral for the rate of
change of stuff equals a surface integral for how
much stuff enters or leaves through the boundary
and gauss's theorem what gauss's theorem allows us
to do is turn that surface integral into a volume
integral so now i can kind of use apples to apples
i can i can add up everything under one common
integral and i now have this partial derivative
expression that has to equal zero everywhere over
all volumes and again if f and if the quantity i'm
adding up if my mass and my momentum or my energy
and my fluid flow are continuous smoothly varying
in space and time then this is true for all
volumes and i can get rid of the volume integral
and i get my partial differential equation so this
is how most of the pdes that you're used to from
classical physics are derived is by writing down
a conservation law and then using gauss's theorem
to kind of simplify um that that conservation law
into a single expression under a common volume
integral okay now again that's this relies on some
continuity that's why it's called the continuity
equation because this relies on you know rho and
f being continuously varying they can't be
really really sharp shock waves in the system
so if there's shock waves in the system other
interesting things will happen and i'll show you
that in a little bit okay awesome thank you and
stay tuned for for kind of the next video on this